[Music]
you've always got ideas every time you
come you've got an idea what's your next
move what's your next move in media I
want to go on Shark Tank
Shark Tank I think I'm gonna go great I
don't I'm not a businessman per se but I
know how to say yes and I know how to
say no wait oh you want to go on Shark
Tank you don't want to be one of the
people that invention you want to be one
of the one of the Sharks I'm a soft baby
I'm this I'm that guy right there yeah
Oh idea no idea at me okay I had an idea
where you could have a potted plant
that's biodegradable the actual pot so
it just it degrades over time so you
don't have to have somebody do yeah okay
mmm see Andy I'm blunt to the point
right no Dilli down around it's rain
you're a shark okay pick the idea right
okay yeah it's a pot knit by Odin I got
it I got it yeah write it down write it
down I said I'd be out of your head get
it out of your head onto paper I put on
paper okay right put it in our middle
envelope right close it right yeah
address that envelope to your ass the
mailman's gonna read the envelope oh I
know what to do and then he's gonna put
away yeah right that's fantastic I don't
like that idea
I hate that ID so okay so you'll be
that's fantastic that'll be a catch
phrase someone all right like a
remote-control girdle for men so that
you didn't have to wear it all the time
but like you'd have a little remote in
your hand so the like if you know you
had a meeting and you had that's tighten
up and be like stop stop right there
stop right there
okay take that idea and get all your
ideas put them all in a blender right
put some ice in it right put a little
milk maybe some juice maybe
[Music]
mmm-hmm get a funnel right gonna follow
with right yeah of course they do
put that funnel in your ass EDM a shark
we're gonna take a break we're gonna
have much much more with j.b smoove he
is just getting started
you